hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the visitor returns I
peered into the future with my bandit
markiplier future vision and I saw the
unrelenting demand for me to play this
game again I see what really happened is
I had so much fun with the first game
that I kind of wanted to see how the
concept would evolve to a sequel and I
don't know how much the concept can
evolve from one point click style horror
game to another but let's see for
ourselves shall we I also don't know if
there are multiple endings in this one
but I would guess yes
click the environment of devourer and
assimilate your prey bonus points for
devouring them through their butts
apparently I hope there's not too much
of that oh hello
you're cute and adorable can I devour
you probably not oh oh why would you
smush me why wouldn't you even try to
eat me you got a little hands why would
you smush me with them
okay mr mr on the raccoon no hammer on
the lock no that would be too smart okay
no not that again you just gotta die
your fingers well
that wasn't me that was my character
being a ding dong okay oh oh is that an
electric mower okay haha okay now I can
come out right no no
well what am I supposed to do how did
that help me oh that would have been
much smarter I'm just so silly why would
I even think of the other end of the
thing to nod okay so oh okay now okay
alright so yeah that's gonna be it that
way why do I have little grubby little
toes that wasn't as horrific as I
thought it was gonna be normally when I
go inside things thanks okay that really
does not need to be taken the wrong way
none of what I say in this video is
going to be in any way in innuendo to
anything else so just keep your minds
out of the gutter please for goodness
sake okay so we got a skunk Rooney over
here yeah okay anyway so what else do we
have here then the newspaper smack No
okay so we got logs logs for the camp
okay logs for the campfire we got this
okay okay good can of beans there we go
okay so I just need to find some way to
light it and probably not anything to do
with the raccoons but or nuts I reckon
that's a skunk yeah whatever no I don't
think I can get over there in any way
just because oh maybe no not quite
yeah okay so I need to find something
that can break open that window because
partially cracked that way I can go in
there I need to find something that can
light well how about a lighter that
would be incredibly convenient okay so
like that that'll like that explode that
very quickly hey where are you going I
know there's a can of beans what were
you scared of oh oh is just taking the
long scenic route around to the can of
beans that exploded okay what was I
thinking
so that's a spider up here my suppose it
oh I'm supposed to do something
oh I'm so sorry what happened to your Oh
oh my god I just really I just realized
like in the first game the only reason I
had that tongue was because I had the
frog in the beginning oh I didn't eat a
frog yet okay okay so things you got to
be something else that I can do I'm over
here now so I imagine there's something
different okay what do I owe
oh yes of course flies flies on there
I'll go over there so I need to go get
it I don't know what that's gonna give
me but it might give me a little bit of
an edge on this skunk why does that make
your butt all big why'd they give you a
badonk well I know why cuz spiders have
big butts but that's not how that works
okay so what can I do with this newfound
power of mine now your powers of but
cannot possibly compete with mine
anything no windows no jokes it off
please
oh that's horrifying oh you blew his
butt off literally like his butthole is
still there what happened to you man
these evolutions this new Pokemon I
don't get it like it's very different
from the first time I watched it okay so
now what the hell am I supposed to do
with this I don't even know where to
begin
do I go back up to the window now
because I can do something oh oh I can
spray skunk juice inside there if there
are humans in there they'll come run it
out right I'm right I'm right oh oh
that's not what I thought was gonna
happen okay Scorpio that's how weird
that supposed to go man supposed to go
on the end of the but I guess my butt's
a little crowded from all the what
that I got back there already hey
Poochie hey bears baby that's a rather
expensive looking bottle of booze you
got there for living in a trailer okay
priorities okay so I can't do anything
until the dog stops barking at me ooh
how about some hot dogs you you a-hole
okay I'm glad I'm not eating that dog
because I would be very sad but this
guy's about to get it back thanks dog
okay so now I need to find a way to I
can't do anything until this dogs gone
oh he's alive in there I only took a
little chunk just to get a little DNA
huh so sad okay hey Lilly yeah
I'm just your old man I ran out of
cranberries young Tammy - was it wd-40
oh that's like bug spray or something
all right so if I take the bug spray
what the hell
that guy just has a knife at the ready
for any time something Crazy's gonna
happen okay so take that Oh combine that
with the button
yeah that's terrifying and he does
nothing about it he has absolutely no
response - what the hell just happened
magically levitating flamethrowers
coming out of nowhere
hey Raj go back to my drink hey I
remember when I used to be a security
guard no one believed me when I said all
the animals were trying to kill me oh
okay so I got it oh now he's flammable
brave oh good good good good
what well that was it oh now he's
distracted kisses arm just magically
where am I gonna eat him from next
things oh god I hate neck what the hell
is that oh is she shooting a gun ah nah
my brains hey lip everywhere what
evolution did I get off of that what why
is any of this a thing okay
alright so I'm back okay so I'm back
outside now she won't suspect it okay
there we go I gotta go in more
stealthily than that she's at the ready
so oh that poor donkey that poor little
doggie okay so what am I supposed to
cool her ha I'll I'll persuade her with
a fresh cold Bruce really oh now she
won't shoot me definitely what hello how
are you
what is it's the choice I have
why isn't she shot me yet how about some
skunk oh oh okay well that's it
oh man but these are my choices I get to
choose between all these oh great oh
okay then
okay well I'm dead I guess that's an
ending lamb these are horrible sound
effects why is this even happening why I
have to do these things
Wow Zoey those dog teeth really do a
number on you good lordy Lou oh god the
sound effects
what oh I'm not done yet
what oh are you serious I'm not done yet
what okay so there's got to be like it
can i I mean I don't wanna but there's
gotta be way like okay how what she's
still there she she's still there oh
okay there we go
she doesn't seem too worried about what
just happened she's just like okay well
it's another Thursday night for me
whatever
[Music]
okay there's a car why I play this game
[Laughter]
[Music]
well there you go I think that's all of
them good golly I I hope you guys got
something out of that ah a little bit of
enjoyment maybe huh why does he want me
well you guys didn't really ask for this
cuz I play this immediately through the
first one but thinking I didn't know
what to expect I guess that's it so
there you go that is the visitor if you
got other games like this eh you want me
to play let me know in the comments
below I will be reading all the
suggestions you put down there and
questioning why I play these games
altogether hey it's for you guys I guess
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done along the same vein as
this I mean technically I played more
gory horror games and this but it is
what it is so thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you
[Music]
it's random